today I'm going to explain the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle and in
case you haven't heard of it the most
common version of the Heisenberg
uncertainty basically says that you
can't know a particles position and its
momentum both perfectly instead the more
you know about one the less you can know
about the other today we're going to
figure out what that actually means if
you remember way back to the first
episode I introduced you to the wave
function which is a wave that tells us
where the particle is most likely to
turn up we said that a particle is most
likely to turn up in areas around where
the wave function is most intense so
from the wave function you can find out
the place that on average most particles
will turn up but of course the average
by itself isn't that useful we'd also
like to know the range around the
average that the particles are most
likely to fall into well for a peak like
this it looks like the particles will
most likely turn up in this kind of
region to calculate this precisely
though we use what's called the standard
deviation this number also gets called
the uncertainty because the bigger it is
the more uncertain we are about where
the particle will be now let's talk
about momentum we know that while we're
not looking a particle must take all
possible Momentum's at once if we plot
all the different momentum so particle
has that also looks like a wave we'll
call this wave the momentum wavefunction
just like with the other wave function
the Momentum's where the wave is most
intense are the more likely to be
measured Momentum's at the moment we
don't know how to find this wave but
we'll get to that later
in the meantime we'll define uncertainty
for the momentum as well in the exact
same way we did with position again this
uncertainty tells us that if you do a
measurement on the particles momentum
you're most likely to find it in that
region so now the Heisenberg uncertainty
is the claim that somehow these two
uncertainties are connected in fact if
you multiply the two the number you get
will always be bigger than this tiny
number here so what does this actually
mean imagine we managed to get the
particle into a state like this now
we're pretty sure about where the
particle will end up however as a result
we don't know very well what momentum
we'll get if we measure it so you see
the uncertainty principle is all about
prediction it restricts how well we can
predict the particles momentum and
position at the same time let's look at
a really interesting example say we go
ahead and measure the particles position
what happens if we decide to measure the
particles position again straight
afterwards well remember that before we
did our measurement the particle was in
a superposition of being in many places
at once
but once we measure it we break that
superposition and now the particle
really is in just one place so if we
measure it again quickly it will in fact
be in the exact same spot okay but what
if we're going to measure the particles
momentum after we measure its position
now your uncertainty of our position is
practically zero so your uncertainty
about momentum is very big this means it
will be really hard to guess the
particles momentum still we go ahead and
we measure the momentum and we get some
number but wait now it looks like we
know the position and the momentum of
the particle perfectly well and doesn't
the uncertainty principle forbid that
well are we sure we know the particles
position what happens if we measure it
again and check the overwhelming chances
are that it will be somewhere other than
where it was the first time why because
by measuring the momentum we actually
change the particles position
wavefunction the particle went from
being in pretty much just one spot to
being in many different spots so you can
see we can never pin down both the
momentum and the position of the
particle why is that the uncertainty
principle isn't just something that we
add into quantum mechanics in an ad hoc
way the reason it happens is because of
a special relationship between the
position wavefunction and the momentum
wavefunction well firstly it's weird
that there should be any relationship
between them at all usually with the
the object's velocity is independent of
its position by that I mean an object
can be moving at all different speeds
regardless of where it is in quantum
mechanics that's just not the case the
position wavefunction actually contains
all the information about the momentum
wavefunction in fact it contains all the
information about the particles state in
general say we're interested in
measuring something else about the
particle like its energy angular
momentum or in the double slit
experiment case which letter went
through you can calculate what values
are most likely to turn up just from the
position wavefunction in other words in
quantum mechanics the wavefunction tells
us everything there is to know about a
particle still there is a particularly
special relationship between momentum
and position that makes the uncertainty
principle happen I'd like to explain it
to you but it's a bit of a detour so I'm
not sure if all of you want to see it
that's why I've decided to make two
short supplementary episodes that will
explain it if you're interested you can
check them out they'll be up soon all
right
see you then